all right you knew it was coming today
you knew that today I was going to tell
you that my pillow CEO and founder Mike
Lindell known to us as pillow the guy
who wants to sue the machines we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines his phone has been seized by
the FBI
at a Hardee's drive-through you really
cannot write this stuff this is
unbelievable
uh you play with fire you might end up
getting burned Daily Beast reports Mike
Lindell feds seized my cell phone at
Hardee's they took my phone the FBI did
look at this video this is pillow
himself explaining the situation last
night
today the FBI uh you're going to hear
this and you're probably already Hearing
in the news the FBI came after me and
took my phone and surrounded me at a
Hardee's and I took my phone and I run
all my business everything went
um
um they could have just what they've
done is weaponize the FBI
um it's disgusting I don't have a
computer everything I do at that phone
everything was on there and uh
um and they told me not to tell anybody
here's an order not to don't tell
anybody okay I won't I am so yep so
there it is Mike pillow raided by the
FBI here he is on the Lindell report
which is hosted by someone else
explaining exactly what happened and
again you cannot write this stuff and
pillow's ability to destroy his own
reputation his own financial future over
nonsense is really incredible and we go
through a Hardy's drive through
we pull around the back and we're just
about going through we pull through the
drive-through to take the order we pull
up and she says pull in
because they had to make the order part
it wasn't done we pull ahead
and a car comes perpendicular and Parks
like a little ways in front of us and I
and I've been around the block and I
said to my buddy I said
um that's either a bad guy or it's it's
FBI which I guess now is the one in the
same for these guys so anyway as you
know I have not been to fast food
restaurants in 20 years other than that
emergency Starbucks stop a few weeks ago
that I told you about I have to imagine
that even within the fast food space
Hardy's is not exactly the best but I
did look it up I found that Hardee's has
a hand breaded chicken biscuit which
sounds pretty good but let's put that
aside for now pillow reportedly worth
300 million dollars at a Hardee's and
gets his phone seized by the FBI now I
think it's important to mention
Mike pillow says that this happened we
don't at this point have independent
confirmation that the FBI actually
seized his phone but let's assume that
he is telling the truth about it and not
making the subhole cloth and on that
basis Donald Trump is absolutely Furious
Donald Trump posting to truth Central
breaking news Mike Lindell the pillow
guy was just raided by the FBI we are
now officially living in a weaponized
police state rigged elections and all
our country is a laughing stock all over
the world the Majesty of the United
States is gone can't let this happen
take back America and pillow is furious
about other things as well let's talk
about that next plastic is everywhere we
look and not enough is being done about
it 100 billion plastic bags are used and
thrown away every year but you can help
make a change our sponsor hold on makes
trash and kitchen bags that are heavy
duty plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part to shop plant-based bags and
replace single-use Plastics all over
your home go to hold on bags.com and
you'll save 20 with the code Pacman at
checkout the link is down below